since we're talking about health
outcomes bad feed breath yep all of that
stuff and resolutions I just think about
your breath stove work on it I came
across I came across a TED talk yeah but
do you really love TED talk yeah yeah
yeah the rodney mullen with the Oh
innovation in skateboarding so I came
across a TED talk which was talking
about an ace score so an ace score means
adverse childhood experiences and it's
basically a tally of different types of
abuse neglect and um or traumas that you
suffer in your childhood yeah Gilbert
stop laughing I don't know why you're
laughing and so based on all these on
this tally can predict whether or not
you have certain types of cancers high
blood pressure or like it's basically a
risk factor for not being healthy as an
adult how many questions are there 10
questions so you guys want to take the
clear Wow you know what I've never been
more excited taking a quiz than this
time okay so don't you excited - these
are we doing it collectively or
individually just you and your brother
says you guys have bad feet so we're
doing it together yes so the higher the
higher your score is the higher your
risk for later health problems let's see
if this is true before your 18th
birthday did a parent or other adult in
the household often or very often swear
at you insult you put you down or
humiliate you or act in a way that made
you afraid that you might be physically
hurt I would have to say yes then well
like is it was the actual act or
verbally abuse basically basically for
verbal what had happened a couple times
but not it was okay with that my dad was
yeah yes yes yes yes yes I'm
yeah did a parent or other adult in the
household often or very often push grab
slap or throw something at you or even
hit you so hard that you had marks or
were injured yes did an adult or person
five years older than you touch or
fondle you or have touched their body in
a sexual note or attempt to have oral
anal or vaginal intercourse with you
nope nope you did
nope it's a no no one got sexually
abused by the podcast five times I was
not used to you though you're free okay
yeah I was in fact I yeah I had some guy
force to suck his dick but five years
old or so Gary five years old five years
or older yeah yeah Gary Allen those guys
don't count yeah they were the older
five years old not under five years no
no no five years older than you older
men older men or like someone older like
fondling each other's teenagers no yeah
that doesn't count so no no no no they
began the [ __ ] guy though no but
that was as we were in Minnesota and he
it was like it was not really touch it
was just weird
it was weird yeah we watch you fondle no
no no Penthouse magazine no you know he
took his fingers in his butthole
I said fingers dick out and I try story
why did you stick fingers in his
butthole so he got molested well you
know who you reminding me of member of
that movie mask with rocky Dennis yeah I
have never met no no no the guy by the
guy by the oh yes yes yeah yeah yeah you
look remind me of that oh yeah I was a
kid move on X course or less yes yeah
for me did you often or very often feel
that no one in your family loved you or
thought you were important or special or
your family didn't look out for each
other feel close to each other support
each other no no no okay good
did you often or very often feel that
you didn't have enough to eat
head to wear dirty clothes and no had no
no no no no no no or your parents were
too drunk or high to take care of you no
no
before your 18th birthday was a
biological parent ever ever lost to you
through divorce abandonment or other
reason nope
was your mother or step mother often
pushed grab slapped or had something
thrown at her
yes yeah yeah yeah did you live with
anyone who has who was a problem drinker
or alcoholic or ever used street drugs
your dad is functioning it doesn't
matter if you had an alcoholic in your
household that's the question yeah he
was before your 18th birthday was a
household member depressed or mentally
ill no no did a household member go to
prison no you're a score is five so a
scores four or higher are not not very
good like basically they want your a
score you're adverse childhood
experiences to be less than four but
also they don't really tell you like the
good parts right to count through the
bad stuff so even that [ __ ] test is
[ __ ] I swear to god there's
something to it though yep you can't you
can't measure love question that's why
it's saying the test tells you in the
beginning that this does this is only a
tally of battery life the leaves do
everything deep okay deep abuse but deep
love deep support extremes yeah it's
stupid it's it's just we're a Korean
right right so what this test is saying
is it doesn't tell you the good stuff so
therefore it doesn't it doesn't take
account what makes you resilient like
your mom's love or your connection as
brothers or other yeah but I still think
that's the reason why your foot that was
the whole point the whole point that's
my foot in his mouth
yeah yes the reason yeah a score of five
gets you that yeah your breath is
because of your alcoholic father that's
the math of that test
[Music]